[Music]
what is
the job of an economic hitman you just
asked the key question
patrick in this hand i'm offering you a
lot of money
for you and your friends and if you
choose not to take it in this hand
i got a gun what would you do i'm an
entrepreneur what do i know i'm just a
regular guy
private plane crash is the best way to
assassinate someone if you ever decide
you want to do that
the corporation business model is we're
going to put you out of business
your business model is more the mafia
business model because it could cost
your life
a few suitcases filled with dollars is
nothing compared to sending in
troops these are bribes sex power
and money do you think china's using any
of that economic hitman
business model you don't want to
negotiate with us you're strong-arming
me watch what i'm gonna do to you
wait a minute wait a minute we we never
created a virus i never said it like
that
i never said bio warfare does that mean
we should retaliate with our own
biological weapons no
not at all what does it mean i'm
learning how you sat down with these
prime ministers and presidents
the glaciers are melting the polar bears
are out there standing on single
icebergs
the oceans are rising species are going
extinct i hope all the audience is
taking notes
we wake up and we look around and say oh
my god
what's happened
[Music]
so my guest today maybe one of the most
interesting guests i've ever had and
i've had a lot of interesting guests let
me explain to why that is
imagine if you are thinking about
writing a book
based on experiences you had that
influence a lot of economies around the
world then you go to 29 publishers
and 29 publishers say we do not want to
touch your book
then eventually somebody picks it up and
the book comes out the title of the book
is called confessions
of an economic hitman it stays on
on a new york times best list for 70
straight weeks
translated in 37 different languages and
sells over a few million copies and you
come out with part two called the new
confessions
of a hitman you write that book and you
end up sharing the stories of people you
were participating with and negotiating
with
imagine writing a book like that and
more importantly imagine living a life
of somebody who has the ability to write
that book that's my guest today
john perkins john thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
patrick it's my pleasure to be here with
you thanks for having me on your show
it's great to have you so so do i go on
craigslist do i go to monster do i go to
courier builder if i'm trying to apply
for a job of wanting to be an economic
hitman
where do i go apply to want to be an
economic hitman how does that happen
well first of all i would suggest that
you don't do it
[Laughter]
you know i thought it was my dream job
until i realized it was my nightmare job
uh yeah and you know that what happened
to me was
when i graduated from business school i
i was trying to avoid the draft the
vietnam draft was was strong then i was
married to a woman whose father was very
high up in the u.s department of the
navy and
his best friend was very high up in the
national security agency the nsa
and that job with the nsa was draft
deferrable
so you know he arranged for me to have
an interview
and i spent a couple of days on most of
it on the lie detector
going through this very very intensive
interview with the national security
agency
and i think you know they they found
that i had three weaknesses
i can go into those if you want but sure
okay so
yeah i grew up in a boys prep school uh
boarding school where my dad taught
and we never had much money and i was
surrounded with kids with a tremendous
amount of money
you know i lived on a house on campus i
had i ate with these boys from the age
of four so i i never wanted for food or
shelter
but we never had much money and i'm
surrounded by these kids who've come
from
every area where you come from they came
some came from tehran
and some of them came from buenos aires
and paris and
park avenue new york very very wealthy i
was always very jealous of their wealth
i i wanted to do things they had done
i also grew up in a place pretty devoid
of women
so i was very shy around women and
i you know i wanted so what the nsa
discovered during these lie detector
tests was that i
really craved sex dr
power and money and that
was that gave them the hook to get in to
get into me
then they actually encouraged me to join
the peace corps for a couple of years
go to the amazon rainforest and you know
the guy who was
high up very high up in the nsa when i
heard i heard about the peace corps
i went to this talk that a peace corps
recruiter gave
at the business school where i was just
about to graduate
and i was very taken by the idea of
going and living with indigenous people
who had always had a fascination about
he encouraged me he said we can help you
get in and we can make sure you go to
the amazon where you live with real
authentic indigenous people
you'll learn another language you learn
survival techniques when you come out
uh you'll be all that much more ready to
work for us but he added one more thing
he said you know you may not actually
end up working for us you may end up
working for a private corporation a lot
of our people do that we have a lot of
our information that way
and that's exactly what happened when i
got out of the peace corps i was
recruited by this private
consulting firm charles t maine and
as an economist and i became chief
economist fairly quickly
and that led to becoming an economic hit
man
that's it in a nutshell now when you
went to the peace corps did you did your
problem of sex power and money get
solved or no
no no not at all and i write about that
you know my most recent book touching
the jaguar i go into some detail
about that i did learn another language
i learned about other cultures i learned
some
incredible survival techniques i at one
point became very very ill
i i couldn't keep any food down i was
dying
and i'm a three-day terrible
adventure to get to the nearest medical
doctor
including a full day hike through a very
dense jungle and then a two days of
riding in a rickety old bus of winding
curvy roads up to about ten thousand
feet altitude
no way i could do it uh the shaman cured
me that night
i can go into that more details you want
to but make a long story short he
he cured me and then required that i
become his apprentice as
as payment for what he'd done for me um
but you know patrick
this is 1969. i'd never even heard of a
shaman
there was no future in shamanism in
those days i sure i surely did not want
to be ashamed
but the guy saved my life you know so as
it turned out that was a very very
fascinating experience because one of
the things that about
it taught me that our reality is totally
molded by our perceptions
its perceptions change everything and
that became very very handy knowledge
for me when i became an economic hitman
because basically economic hitmen use
perception
to mold reality very very very
interesting transition from there by the
way
before we go into the economic hitman
what were some of the interesting
questions if you remember that the nsa
asked you in the interview well here's
here's here's an example they asked me
you know how i felt about the vietnam
war and i
i'm on a lie detector i was truthful i
said i
i have no desire to go off and kill
people who have never done any harm to
me
or be killed by them and i don't think
they're a threat to our country
well i thought that was totally screw me
you know they would be interested in me
after i said that
another one was when i was in in college
when i was
earlier before i went to business school
i was at middlebury college
i had a good friend there who was
iranian
and uh um he his father was actually
a general in the shah's army
uh and uh one night
uh uh we're at this bar we're at this
kind of disco tech
again the details are in the touching
the jaguar we were at this bar
and and i ended up getting sucker
punched by a big farmer
from the hills of vermont and and
my friend fahad this that wasn't his
real name i don't
use his real name but i can give it to
you but he
he pulls out and he had this technique
he showed me before he'd been a
professional soccer player for the club
of rome he was older than
anybody else in his class at middlebury
he'd taken time off played soccer
and he had this he carried the small
jackknife
and he'd put his thumb up along the
blades of just a little tip of the blade
show
and he showed me how he done this and
that this night he did it he swept it
across the guy's cheek
and of course the guy thinks he's been
stabbed by a knife that's just a
it's really just a little pin prick but
it draws blood it scares this farmer
it's terrified him he screams out
and and fajard grabs me pushes me into
the men's room
we jump out the window into the otter
creek the river down below
we go we get back to the dorm and
the next morning i'm picked up by the
campus police
they take me to the police station i'm
sitting there waiting in the waiting
room of the police station
and outcomes for heart from another room
with a closed door he's not allowed to
talk to me they usher him out they
usher me in and they they grill me on
this and i
i totally lied i said oh i didn't see
anything happen no as far as i know
nothing happened we
we left i don't know anything happened i
totally lied
and now i'm under a lie detector test
with the nsa and they say
have you ever had any run-in with the
police
and i have to tell them and so now i've
got these two counts against me there
are some other things that went on you
know
we went into the thing about obsession
with women with sex
but totally shy and and also
i've i've said i'd post the vietnam war
i've lied to the police
well i later discovered they loved that
the fact that i had the guts
to lie to the police was the kind of
person the nsa
wanted and and
the fact you know that that they didn't
care about the vietnam war this was
they already knew at this point this was
1968 they
they basically knew we'd lost vietnam
and the nsa didn't they they didn't care
that wasn't a problem for them so these
things that i thought were
against me one that they didn't care
about the other one really served to my
advantage
and the fact that and of course i didn't
know uh the connection at that point
that that fahad and his father who was a
general in the in the
in the military had a very very strong
connection with the nsa
so you know these things at the time
that i thought were just going to screw
me
actually work to my advantage in your
favor wow that's interesting so
so you know for for those who haven't
read your story who haven't read the
book
what is the job of an economic hitman
well and again you know my official
title was chief economist
economic hitman was it was kind of like
calling a cia operative
a a spy you know you know you don't call
them that
but um my job really and i had a
i had several dozen people very highly
qualified young people working for me
but my job was to identify countries
with resources our corporations wanted
like oil in iran for example and then in
in most of these countries arrange huge
loans to that country now iran was an
exception there they didn't need loans
we just wanted their oil that's another
story but in general
it was to arrange a huge loan to that
country from the world bank or one of
its sister organizations
but the money never actually went to the
country instead it went to our own
corporations in the united states to
build big infrastructure projects
in the country things like power systems
electric power systems
industrial parks highways ports
so the country was put into debt took on
these huge
loans and the collateral was the
resource that was usually still in the
ground
like oil and then our companies were
made these huge profits
by building these big projects these
infrastructure projects
and you know
i went in with the belief that this
would help
the people of the country become more
prosperous and these were poor countries
for the most part
and that this would help them become
more prosperous because in business
school i was taught that
and the economic models show it that if
you invest
a large amount of money in
infrastructure
the gdp the gross domestic product grows
it does and so all the models tell you
this is the way to help a country
but over time as i was in this job for
10 years
and perhaps because i'd been in the
peace corps i began to understand
that actually it wasn't the poor people
weren't getting any better off
and the middle classes were getting
poorer actually it was
just a few rich families that were
making a lot of money
and what we know now is that these
statistics are very skewed
so gdp is a reflection of how well the
wealthy are doing
it's not a reflection of how well
everybody's doing for example if
you take the united states today there's
three individuals
that have as much wealth as half the u.s
population
if those three individuals made a return
on their investments last year
of 10 and half the u.s population
lost lost 3 percent we should still show
a gain in
gdp of something close to five percent
so we see that that you know this whole
idea that the shaman taught me that
perception molds reality
the creating a perception that gdp
is benefited by infrastructure that's
true
but the perception is that gdp reflects
how well
the country's doing for everybody and it
doesn't that's a false perception
in almost all cases it took me a long
time to
to to understand that once i understood
it
i really didn't want to believe it
patrick because i was making
a lot of money i was now getting all the
things
that i had told the nsa i wanted i was
getting lots of sex
lots of money and lots of power and i
was whining and dining with presidents
you know uh
one of them sitting behind you there and
in the picture
behind you the shah veron and you know
so
so once i knew what i was doing was not
what i
pretended to be doing what i prayed
myself to be doing helping poor people
i didn't want to admit it i didn't want
to believe it i wanted to
keep buying into the procession because
i thought i was living the american
dream and i didn't want to let go of it
john so if we can go back to the system
so
if you if you were to tell me a step
process would you say step number one
identify a nation that has a lot of
resources that we need that we can uh
monetize that they're not doing well
financially would you say that's step
number one
yes okay what's step number two step
number two is to send somebody like me
and an economic hitman in to convince
the president or the minister of
financer
whoever is in control that they need to
accept a huge loan
from the world bank or the asian
development bank or the inter-american
development bank or
one of these organizations and you use
that money to hire
u.s corporations to build big
infrastructure so
got it so you actually so you do a study
to to show that if they invest
let's say a few billion dollars in
today's terms
into building an electric system you
show that for the next 20 years
the economy is going to grow at a pretty
pretty high rate
got it so so number one identifying
nation number two go send somebody like
yourself a chief economist
aka economic hitman to meet with
the ministry of finance or the pm or the
president whoever it is the main leader
and tell them we can go to world bank
and get a loan for this much money and
have american business create
infrastructure in your country and
that's going to create a lot of jobs
and it's going to benefit you and in
that conversation that you're having
with them is that a forced conversation
or is that a butter
smooth amicable everyone's going to win
what kind of a conversation is that
you just asked the key question patrick
it's a so
you go in and you're on with a very
sophisticated report that your financial
experts the guys who work for me they
you know we've produced econometric
models fancy
you know mathematical models to show
how everything would benefit how much
industry would grow and how much
so on and so forth you go in and you
hand this to the president and you
basically say hey
mr president if you take this loan on
and it's going to really benefit you
and your family and all your friends
because your family and your friends
own the industries they own the banks
they own the commercialist
establishments and all of those are
going to benefit from infrastructure
oh and by the way uh our our
construction companies are going to hire
your brother-in-law's firm
that happens to lay pipe and and your
sister
owns the john deere franchise we'll
we'll we'll run a lot of john deere
equipment and
we'll pay top dollar for we're not going
to try to negotiate her down we're going
to negotiate
her up in fact you actually you end up
often
let's say paying 2 million to rent
equipment that should only cost you a
million dollars
it's a bribe but it's a legal bribe
nobody can find you fault if you're made
of a lousy decision and paid too much
and practically nobody's gonna even look
but if they did it would they you know
you'd get out
so you all these ideas oh and
incidentally mr president
you and your all your ministers and your
cabinet all of their children
are going to get scholar we're going to
help them get into colleges my company
was in boston a lot of good colleges
we had a lot of context we're going to
get them into the best colleges
in boston area and we're going to give
them full scholarships
and we're going to give them jobs during
christmas vacation and summer and when
they get out of college they have
guaranteed jobs with us
these are bribes but actually we went
out and we talked to the press the
boston globe the boston media
and we said hey you know we gave a
million dollars last year in
scholarships to kids from poor countries
we don't mention that those were the
kids who didn't need the scholarships
but so there were all the you know they
were very strict anti-corruption laws in
the united states in those days and i
guess they still
are but there's so many ways to get
around them and
we we knew all those ways to get around
them so you go in and you tell the
president this
you stay so buy into this loan and he
says but
we should take on this huge debt and
what means we're going to have to take
money away from
education and social services and and
health care
to pay the interest on the debt and we
say yes but you're going to make a lot
of money you and your family so he knows
that he's doing something that's
probably not going to help his people
but it's going to help him
and then you also say but if you don't
choose to take the
this uh if you don't choose to take this
deal
remember what happened to muhammad
mosaddy
in iran remember what happened to
salvador allende
in chile remember what happened to
arbenz and guatemala and siam and
vietnam and lumumba in the congo
these are all presidents or prime
ministers
who refused to play the game and were
taken out in coups or assassinations
and so basically we're saying remember
there's people we call jackals
behind the scenes so basically i'm
saying hey mr president
in this hand i'm offering you a lot of
money for you and your friends
but in the and if you choose not to take
it in this hand
i got a gun no i didn't actually carry a
gun
but i knew those guys were basically cia
assets
behind me that had guns and you know the
classic cases the original
case was was kermit roosevelt who who
overthrew
prime minister mosidek in iran and
replaced him with the shah and that was
that set a precedent
and these presidents all know this they
know
they know the history they know they
will be taken out if so
so what's the choice you know patrick
what would you do
let me ask you when you are saying it
how are you saying it to me like
i know the way you just said it right
now how would you say it to me if i'm
the shop iran and you're sitting with me
and you're telling me here's the options
let me
if you if you could role play with me
what would it be like how would you say
yeah first of all with the shot we
didn't we didn't play quite that game
because he had plenty of money he didn't
have to take a loan
we were just trying to convince him that
he he ought to work with us rather than
the soviet union
that he ought to you know we wanted his
oil
and we were willing to help him
westernize his country and we didn't
want he didn't want to go to the soviet
roots that was a little bit different
give me an example of somebody who you
did what yes
okay let's say i'm talking to you you're
you're the president of colombia
okay and and we want to get at your
resources there and
and i'm saying to you i'm showing you
all these fancy reports that show how
well your country's going to do and you
can show these reports to your press and
to your people you can convince your
people
that by taking on these loans you're
helping the country you're going to
build these big dams you're going to
build these big
electrical systems whatever so you get
all the material you need here and and
it's
usually a series of meetings maybe some
of them over lunch with a few cocktails
et cetera and
the president's maybe electing a little
and then you you just sort of suddenly
start talking about
you somehow you bring up the topic of
what happened recently to salvador
allende in chile
or what happened to arbenz and guatemala
depending on what part of the world
you're in you talk about these people
and you say you know isn't that a shame
and you talk a little bit about this
you know depending on the president
different presidents you you approach
differently
and that they get it i mean they know
the history it doesn't
you know these guys know what's going on
and their advisors know what's going on
and they're usually sitting there at the
meetings too some pretty smart advisors
who probably
you know been to business called the
same business schools that i went to and
so forth
and there everybody's you know i i speak
spanish but
half most of the people in the room can
speak english too and they they fit
you know they get the same background
but i will say patrick and i mentioned i
talked in the book about two presidents
who did not play the game
democratically elected president of
ecuador jaime rodos
and the head of state of panama or
monterrijos
they had tremendous integrity they saw
what i was trying to do
and they didn't do it and
they they understood the dangers they
were taking and they talked about these
things
and both of them were were i believe
assassinated they were they were both
taken out and it's
too almost a little over two months
apart from each other in 1981
they were taken out in in their private
planes
in ecuador first with jaime roldos his
private plane crashed
very suspicious circumstances and
less than three months later same thing
happened to omar torrijos in panama
these were the only two guys
that stood up to this that said we're
not buying these deals and in fact
made a big point uh public relations
they went up there and made very strong
statements and they set examples for the
world
and they were taken out in these plane
crashes
and although there was never a smoking
gun found
because in a plane crash the smoking gun
goes up in smoke
plane crashes private plane crashes the
best way to assassinate someone if you
ever
decide you want to do that and
because the evidence is gone but in the
case of
at least one of those cases jaime rodosa
the plane's engines were sent to a
laboratory in
in switzerland or sweden switzerland
um and they concluded that the plane had
not
crashed it had blown up in the air and
so
um and there was tremendous other
evidence there's tremendous evidence
that
it points to these having been
assassinations how much longer were
those assassinations after you sat down
with them
uh well with omar torrijos that i've
been sitting down with him since
mid seventies and this happened in 81 so
this has gone on he'd meanwhile
negotiated the panama canal treaty with
jimmy carter
which turned the canal over to the
panamanians
at the end of the at the end of the
millennium
and uh rolos had only been president for
a couple of years
so i've been a fairly short period with
roll dos
roll roaldos died first he was a lawyer
he was a college professor
he'd run on a on a campaign platform
of forcing the oil companies and that
was texaco from the united states
primarily to pay a fair share of its
profits
that are made from ecuadorian oil to the
ecuadorian people
it was a pretty reasonable thing and
they said if they don't do it i'm going
to nationalize them
and of course the oil companies didn't
like that any and i couldn't talk him
out of it
i couldn't talk him to take these deals
and he goes down in this plane crash
right after that plane crash happened
ronaldo
excuse me torrijos got his family
together and and i know some of the
members that were there personally
and said my brother heine rodos of
ecuador
was just assassinated by the cia
and i'll be next probably but he said
you know
don't worry about it because i've
accomplished i've accomplished the
biggest thing that i wanted to
accomplish and that is i got the canal
back in the hands and the canal zone
back in the hands of panamanians i
successfully negotiated that contract
so i'm ready to go and he stuck to his
guns
well i suppose that was a poor turn or
phrase there
he got taken out but very few presidents
had that kind of you get
guts or insanity you know i mean you
know and it still goes on i mean
presidents of these countries are in
very very
very difficult positions so so let me
ask you this so so
if we go back to the system number one
identify the nation that qualifies for
what you're looking for number two
go in and get a loan from a world bank
and create businesses there and jobs
and in return we're going to take care
of your kids we're going to put them at
harvard we're going to put them at brown
we're going to put them at columbia
we're going to put them at yale
full-ride scholarship all this other
stuff you're going to be fine and we're
going to pay you some kind of an income
number three if you don't here's what
could happen to you that happened to the
following six seven eight people
that's the business model is that pretty
accurate what the business model is
yes up until that point yes okay so
who came up with this business model is
there somebody that you guys say well
the founder of this business model was
john doe who
used to be xyz and he taught us to do
this because it worked back in the
whatever hundreds
is there somebody that invented this
system was was it purely accidental
well you know empire the idea of forming
empires is as old as
you know modern sort of modern history
it's as old as history basically
um but the real turn
happened in iran in the early 1950s
so when prime minister that gets uh
elected president and again very much
much like honey roll dose
he ran on a platform that said the oil
companies
we need the oil companies here but
they've got to pay pay a fair share of
the profits they make in iran to the
iranian people
and the british and the americans where
the oil companies
in play here especially the british
company the company that became bp
and the british had no did not have a
relationship with iran so they called on
the americans
and it was eisenhower first it was
truman truman refused to get involved
and then eisenhower became president he
got involved and he tried to convince
uh most of that to uh to change his ways
and but it wasn't happening
now eisenhower you know ex-military
general was very afraid of nuclear war
with the soviet union
and iran borders the soviet union so he
didn't want to send troops in because he
was afraid that the soviets would
respond by sending their own troops in
and it could escalate to a nuclear
war and so he got together his secretary
of state and his head of cia who are the
dulles brothers the infamous
allen and john foster dulles and they
came up with this plan
and the plan was that they identified a
cia agent a card-carrying cia agent
named kermit roosevelt
who happened to be teddy roosevelt's
grandson
and kermit roosevelt was sent off to
iran
with literally with suitcases filled
with
dollars and a few friends and he
had a few you know assistants and they
launched this
huge campaign to discredit most of that
and you know they they bribed the police
they bribed hoodlums in the streets to
go demonstrate in the streets they
bribed the press
they used this money to convince the
country
that or at least to convince our country
to convince the world in a way that that
this
prime minister was very unpopular and
that he was a soviet puppet that he was
a communist and of course this is in the
in a time in the early 50s when when
there was this huge
clash between communism and capitalism
you know with the cold war had really
begun
uh and so there was this and in the
united states huge amounts of press that
that that that was paid for to to to say
that this guy had to be taken out
and so eventually he was overthrown and
it seemed like a legitimate coup
against a guy who was evil to his
country this is this is
you know the impression that was
conveyed to the world and
the charvaran was brought in
as a cia puppet basically and placed on
the throne the peacock throne
and so but this was so successful
and it was so inexpensive you know a few
suitcases filled with dollars is nothing
compared to sending in
troops and it was so safe in terms of if
if if if it didn't work
then there probably wouldn't have been
war who knows what would have happened
to kermit roosevelt but but there
wouldn't have been a war we wouldn't
we wouldn't there was no threat of
nuclear war that it
it it marked a turning point where
successive uh administrations in the
united states
could say now listen we don't have to go
to war
to exploit other countries we can do it
economically
there was one problem and that was that
kermit roosevelt was a card-carrying cia
agent
if he had been caught it would have been
very embarrassing for the cia for the us
government
so very shortly after that the decision
was made to use private consultants like
me
[Music]
i thought it would wouldn't implicate
the us government
got it so this is why when you went to
your nsa interview
they said you may we may not hire you
but you may work with one of the
companies
that we are in partnership with exactly
and that became a very common practice
now let me ask you how many times did
the nsa throw companies like that under
the bus saying we had nothing to do
with it we had no business with them was
it pretty common practice throw the
companies under the bus once somebody
screwed up
well we always knew that they they would
do that uh
if we if we screw it up but i don't know
how many that actually happened to it
because i think
in general uh you know
we were pretty successful people in my
position were pretty successful because
these
heads of states of these countries had
damn few options really i mean they
they knew the options
how many economic hitmen like you were
there at the time in america
i don't know i never did no i never did
know
but what i do know and why i wrote the
follow-up to confessions of an economic
hitman 12 years later the new
confessions is because i
that that whole species has grown so
much over the years
and it's not only people like me who are
kind of generic we wanted to arrange
deals that would help u.s corporations
and we didn't really care
whether bechtel got the contract or
brown and rude or
or halliburton or general electric we
didn't really care who
the contractor as long as we got a piece
of the action and we made sure that we
would get a piece of the action
but now in addition to people like like
that who are still out there
every major corporation has its
equivalent of economic hitman so
you know so whether it's it's raytheon
or
general dynamics or 3m or
general electric or walmart for that
matter
they all have people that are going out
into these countries
and and trying to arrange better deals
for their for their company
and you know we see that so blatantly
when a company decides that it's going
to build
we even see it within the united states
so remember when amazon was going to you
know put in their next headquarters
office they they got
northern virginia to die with new york
city and what they were asking they had
these economic hit men going in and
telling
and selling tony says hey look you'll
get a lot of employment here if we move
our headquarters here
or part of our headquarters here but you
gotta give us a big tax break and you
gotta
you gotta give us a low uh wage rates
that we can deal with
and so you don't think you don't think
that's appropriate just to kind of put
that you don't think that's an
appropriate uh
thing to do for a company to say if i
bring you 22 500 jobs
at 150 000 your income give me some tax
breaks you don't think that's the right
thing to do it's what you're saying
well i think we have to be careful i i
think that i i i i
i'm not sure there's a general rule but
i think what we have to look at is what
are the trade-offs in new york city
actually
won the contract with amazon and then
decided that they weren't going to
accept it because it was a bad deal for
them
so if you give the company such tax
breaks but
i don't think new york city said no
though i think aoc campaigned around it
saying the fact that the rent is going
to go up and
both de blasio and uh uh
uh uh what's the governor's name uh
cuomo but
the palacio cuomo wanted it but aoc's
campaign drove bezos away and bezos
finally said i'm not gonna put it here
so
new york wanted it but aoc kind of
pushed them away well
yeah who does aoc represent you know i
mean
obviously she's a she's a a big
supporter of the socialistic philosophy
and cuomo and de blasio kind of wanted
those jobs in new york
and you would think that cuomo and and
bellatio would be
more powerful than her wouldn't you
actually i mean they they've got the big
corporations behind them i don't think
so i think because
nowadays you know one of your talks you
gave which was very powerful you said
uh uh i don't know if it was your tedx
or i don't know which
interview you did you talked about the
fact that the power people have today to
send emails to companies to talk about
the fact that hey
let's do more social let's give back to
community let's use our power and
resources to
send an email people are listening
nowadays there's this thing that emailed
today called twitter
well aoc has nearly 8 million twitter
followers that's more than both of them
combined times 10
you know times six so you have to
realize that it's it's different today
just because you're a mayor of new york
or governor of new york doesn't mean you
have more influence than somebody that's
a congressman
with 8 million followers one's got a
bigger voice than the rest do
and is that democracy in the works
um i mean it's called marketing to me
it's not democracy
i think yeah there's always been a fine
there's always been a fine line there
hasn't there between democracy
in any case you know i don't know you
know who's right or wrong but the point
being
that you know do you bring a company in
and offer them huge tax breaks
but at the same time you give them huge
benefits in terms of the school system
the fire departments the police
departments the sewage systems all these
other things that the company benefits
from the airports
do do they pay their fair share and
that's a question i think every
community has to
ask itself and we see the same thing in
countries so we've got
a company going in and talking to
indonesia saying hey if you let us build
our next plant here
uh and we will build our next plant here
if you'll give us big tax breaks
and if you don't we'll go to the
philippines and
these countries you know always have to
look at this and and nine times out of
ten
in my experience it's the wealthy people
who benefit
so you give the company the tax breaks
and the wealthy people somehow end up
getting the kind of deals that i
described where their brothers get these
contracts and their system
and so on and so forth so but i think
you know that's why i say i don't think
there's a general answer to your
question i mean tax breaks can be used
very very wisely
but they can also be a very corrupt form
of of uh
companies getting things for free that
they probably should be paying for
and i also think patrick an argument
could be made to let's not tax
corporations at all
but let's let's really tax the people
who benefit from them the stockholders
especially the wealthiest stockholders
who to pay their fair share i mean
there's so many different ways to look
at this whole process of how do we
how do we support our police forces and
our fire departments and our hospitals
and our schools
and our utility companies who who pays
who pays the price for these things i
mean
listen we're going into a whole
different conversation because if you if
you think about that part
you know i'd much rather have amazon go
to new york and go to dc
because if you go to dc that's the
ultimate crony capitalism business model
where you are now in the
you know you you know what it costs to
senators pass a law nowadays i think
it's fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars
doesn't cost that much money to do some
of that so you know if they go to new
york and then i think from the
governor's standpoint like i moved my
business from la to here
okay when i moved here i brought all the
jobs here
and you know every uh a race
everything that we did texas got the
benefit of the people that are living
here whether they bought homes they get
their kids sent to kids to private
school
all the money they spent at the market
you know gas
all of that stuff texas benefit from it
california lost from it right and you've
seen a lot of that
elon musk just put his plant in um
austin so i'm i'm just thinking
economically how that makes sense
for some states i understand the benefit
of having 22
500 jobs painted on an average of 150
bring it to my city i'd love to find a
way to make it work with you if i'm a
governor
or mayor at that time but going back to
the business model you're talking about
it
it got me thinking so one find
a country that's somewhat desperate has
resources number two
go in and make an offer with the
corporation hey
world bank lends us four billion dollars
we're gonna build infrastructure into
your country it's gonna
create a bunch of different jobs three
wink wink will take care of your kids
private school all this other stuff
that's gonna happen four if you don't do
we're gonna kill you so
the corporation business model is we're
going to put you out of business
your business model that you had that
you were working with is more the mafia
business model because it could cost
your life if you don't do it
those six stories that you have how much
of that do you think is happening today
with other countries doing it to america
well that's a that's an interesting
question
uh can you be more specific for example
you know
uh i don't know let me go in and
i'm uh china you know if you look at
like 30 years ago russia was the enemy
today it's china's the enemy okay
china's
surpass russia as an enemy and china
comes in and says hey
mcconnell i know your wife's uh uh
father is uh a very very well-known
billionaire in china
you know we'll do this for you just kind
of be a little bit lenient with us
but we'll take care of you hey biden you
know if you allow us to do this one and
a half billion dollar deal
we'll put your son on the board and pay
you 50 000 it's a form of an economic
hitman
that that's what i'm saying how much is
how much of that
is china studied what u.s did and now
china's saying we're going to take it to
a whole different level
do you think china is using any of that
economic hitman business model
you know i i i i hate to speculate and
stuff i don't really know and i don't
really know what's going on now
in those terms the united states except
what i read or hear
i i certainly would expect that china
would be trying to do that
because that's that is part of the model
what i
what i do know is what china has been
doing in
in latin america for example where i
still spend a lot of time
i spent a in a normal year i spent two
to three months
in in latin america and ecuador colombia
costa rica guatemala
and many places and i've seen in the
bahamas i've seen
how china is making huge inroads into
these countries
um you know china's playing the same
game that we did in a way of making
these
these huge loans and it's got these two
big banks the asian infrastructure
investment bank and brics uh
bank that are that are outspending the
world bank
and getting very being very very
successful at it
and china's been making a lot of
mistakes uh it built a huge dam in
ecuador that's got cracks in it because
they built it on a fault line that
sort of hacked volcano and crazy stuff
there's a hotel that was built in
in the caribbean that the chinese built
and the pipes that
the toilet pipes are all too small i
guess the chinese people are
smaller so i don't know what the story
is there but they had to
then completely re-plum the whole system
and they had to put they couldn't go
back in the wall so they had to put the
pipes on the outside of the walls huge
terrible mistake you know they've been
making some big mistakes
but what china has done differently in
the united states
and i i i asked my friends in high
places and
in some of the latin american countries
why are you taking loans from china
don't you think that they're
they're going to do the same thing that
you you know that's coming out we'd much
rather take loans from china than nine
states and say but wait
aren't they after your resources too and
they say yeah they're after our
resources we don't have the technology
to mine to to drill for oil to do these
things so we need outside company
country to help us and we know that the
united states has a record of
overthrowing our governments
and assassinating leaders we all know
that and
of building military bases on our soil
and forcing us to vote against cuba and
the united nations doing things
exercising huge controls over us and
china hasn't done that china's not built
any military bases here they've not
taken out any of our presidents they've
not
been involved in any coups and so we'd
prefer to take loans from them
so and i'm not i'm not defending what
china is doing by any means because i
think their motives are the same but i
will say that i think that they're
they may have learned from our mistakes
from the us's mistakes and
being quite so blatant as we've been in
some of these places
so they're very much using the same
techniques that i used
except maybe they're not holding the gun
up
quite the same way they're basically oh
they're basically offering the money and
you know china has this long history of
huge amounts of exploitation out into
the world through commerce very seldom
has it used military might except in
what it considers its own sphere of
influence which is
uh which is uh tibet
and uh the south china sea and in taiwan
but it it's it's it's it's used the you
know the silk road it's uses
this this very commercial uh form of
exploitation
uh to create its own version of empire
so let me ask you who do you trust more
yourself you've been all over the world
you've represented us you've dealt with
a lot of different countries
do you do you trust china more do you
trust u.s
more politically in america i'm i'm an
american i trust the united states
uh that i and i'm also sad that we made
some of the mistakes that we made in the
past that have put us in this position
that's one of the reasons i write the
books i write
and why i'm talking to you because i
think we've made some big mistakes and i
think we need to
really look at those mistakes and
correct them i think we should be the
world leader
we should lead the world into democracy
and a good form of capitalism
and uh we have not done a very good once
the soviet union collapsed in 91
we had an opportunity to really get out
there and show the world how how
benevolent we could be how
how we could really set a model for the
world and we didn't do a very good job
at it and now the chinese are stepping
in
and telling the world that they can do a
better job i don't think they can do a
better job
i'm an american i want to and i want to
see us resume the leadership role and do
it in
a way that will convince the rest of the
world that our system is the best
john how much are you following the
election right now how much are you
following
the story of the election right now
going back and forth between biden and
trump
well yeah i'm following it i don't know
you know how how much what do you mean
how much can you follow it's in the new
i listen to the news every day and the
reason why i'm asking that is because
you know when i asked a question about
mcconnell and if there was a model of
economic hitman being used for them
for chinese to potentially try to win
over mcconnell or biden you kind of
skim pass through it but you're somebody
that this is like your cup of tea this
is your world i mean i would assume
you'd be an expert to give us feedback
to see
if if let's just say china was
uh bringing a deal in one and a half
million dollars in investing
and paying fifty thousand dollars a
month to somebody's son is that a model
of an economic hitman
is that it is so that is a model of an
economic hitman
yeah if that's what's happening yes it's
the same it's very similar to the model
that i
i did what i was basically saying
patrick is you know
i i i like to have a lot of credibility
and i think i do
in on on from all parties i don't i
don't take a political stance
and i intentionally uh i mean i have my
own politics but i don't try to bring it
in i want to be
i talk about what i know what i've
experienced and what i was
basically saying is right now i'm not in
that business and so it's hard to
comment on it
i can comment and i haven't had
conversations with the leaders of the
united states
in in quite a few years i do have
conversations
fairly frequently with leaders of south
america i was just on a program the
other day with the
former president of colombia and also
with the former president of ecuador and
i
i i'm in conversation with leaders in
other countries much more than i am with
my own country
so so uh okay so at the same time
you know one thing that makes you very
interesting is when you speculate
what happened with a uh i think john f
kennedy you've speculated that john f
kennedy could potentially be an inside
job right like meaning the assassination
was
possibly done from the inside yes or you
don't have any speculation with john f
kennedy
well no i don't have any speculation i i
only read the what the papers say what
we've heard and and
and the u.s congress and the joint
commission
uh ruled against the idea that there was
one assassin on the other hand
i guess it was the fbi have ruled that
there was one assassin i don't pretend
to know
i think there's always that possibility
that
might there might have been more to it
than we than we know but i certainly
don't have any
reason to suspect otherwise
personally got it and have you ever
commented on mlk if mlk was potentially
assassinated
uh or no any thoughts on that with your
experience
martin luther king yeah well he
obviously was assassinated
was it an inside job oh no i don't think
i've ever speculated i don't speculate
on that i have no idea
got it no you know i i wonder because
you know sometimes you sit there and you
you read these stories you know i was
born in iran and i
sometimes wonder shah's exodus how much
of that you hear the
the stories of both sides you know on
one end
carter comes in toast leaves
the revolution begins they bring
somebody from france
paris that was exiled twice khomeini he
lives over there he's sending these
tapes they're spreading 12 months later
the
momentum gets very high you know let's
blame savak no let's blame
no more laws no let's blame you know the
shah no let's blame khomeini's people
and then there's a cinema rex fire which
i'm sure you remember where 400 people
were in a
theater in abadan and all these guys
folks die you know was savakis there no
cops right across the street whose fault
was it
and then some say america caused the
revolution in iran and some say the
people of iran were just sick of it
from your experience of having been
around a lot of those people what would
you say
your opinion on what happened with iran
with the end of shah's regime
well first of all i was shocked at what
happened in iran
and my own personal experience was
one night i'm sitting in the
the tehran hilton sorry the
intercontinental in tehran
at the at the bar i was staying there
and i'm sitting at the bar and i get a
tap on the shoulder and i turn around
and there's a man behind me
who i recognize and it's for heart the
guy who i went to middlebury college was
and got in the knife
soccer incidentally he got expelled uh
for being in that night fight
uh they did they did pin it on him i
even though i denied it
um and uh he tasked me on the shoulder
he's standing behind me and i haven't
seen
him in many years well over 10 years
uh he's gained a lot of weight but i
recognize him and
and we we we test we we we just chat for
a few minutes
and then he said john i've got a ticket
here in my hand you're flying out with
me on
an air france tomorrow morning at 5 00
am to to
rome and i said well no i've got a
meeting tomorrow with a
somebody somebody very high up in the
shah's administration
and he said no you're not you're going
with me
to rome you we're going to go and stay
in my dad's house
and i said well your dad is a as a
general in the shah's army he's here
he's not in rome and
and heart said no he's he's always a
house in rome he's kept it and he's
he's living there now he's he's left
around permanently
and you're coming with me and and i got
on
the plane with him the next morning and
it was the next
day all that next week that the things
erupted in iran that the beginning of
the revolution
happened and i never and and i
went and i stayed at uh at uh the
general's house
in rome for a couple of days and and you
know i said so what's going on he said
well the shah has lost it he's he's out
he's he's never going to make it and and
and this guy says i think that has lost
his mind to a certain degree he's not
he's not the guy he used to be and
you know i never really understood what
went on because
from my perspective and most everybody
that i knew
that was working in iran the shah was
very popular you know his picture was
everywhere
he and and the princess pharaoh that
that his wife
their pictures were everywhere and
people seemed to really love them we
thought they did and then she was
sponsoring
international tennis tournaments and and
film festivals
and bringing a lot of culture to the
country um
and uh we had this impression
and so i was shocked totally shocked but
you know over the years people pointed
out to me that all the information
i ever got in iran came from people
iranians who spoke english
who were mainly educated in the united
states or england and they all worked
for the shah ultimately you know
one form or another all so whenever i
was out interviewing people who didn't
speak english i had
interpreters there with me who spoke
english so
you know it was portrayed to me that i
didn't really understand the
tremendous undercurrent against the shah
i don't know whether it was there or not
i've been told i just didn't
see it or hear it because i i wasn't
privy to that information
unlike in latin america where i could
always hear the undercurrent
of some of the anti-americanism that was
going on there's some of the fear of
exploitation because i'm fluent in
spanish so i could talk to
you know street sweepers i could talk to
you know carpenters and people of the
street it wasn't just
i didn't have to do anything through an
interpreter i didn't do anything for an
interpreter
so there's a big difference so in iran
we i was very much
blindsided and i think most everybody
was i mean companies lost a lot of money
my own company lost a lot of money it
was interesting
patrick that my company charles t maine
in all these countries where we worked
we
we usually were paid by the world bank
or one of those organizations so
we didn't worry about getting paid the
money came directly to us from the world
bank it never went to colombia or
guatemala or ecuador
that they they signed off on the loan
but the money went directly from
the world bank to our banks and so we
didn't worry
in the one country where we that and if
countries did owe us money we insisted
on being paid
before we produced the report so we'd go
in and do the work and then we have a
report that they wanted but we wouldn't
give it to him until we get paid
iran was the one exception we trusted
iran
we trusted the shah and so
my company lost a lot of money after the
after the overthrow after the coup with
the overthrow of the shah
uh and uh you know so we were totally
blindsided and we just didn't have any
idea we thought the place was safe it
was it was a very
interesting thing as i as i look back on
it to think of how
how naive we were i guess then again
i don't know was there a big
undercurrent i i still don't know
you know what what the story is and it's
i mean it's been 30 years since
since the event happened you even hear
cia reports saying the fact that
uh there was involvement with u.s
wanting to get him to fall
and uh for the shot to have a fall so
you read a lot of different stories i
just thought maybe if you have been
involved in that
maybe you would have certain right that
we don't have
i can't imagine that they wanted the
mullahs to take over
like i just can't see you know how that
served
any u.s interest
but yes because at that time there was
an element
of uh them being more reasonable and the
show was getting a little too powerful
in the
co in the world and they were getting
ready to pass uk
and uk used to own the
you know anglo persian oil company that
turns out to become you know you know
this bp years later and back in the days
they used to own ninety percent of it
and iran didn't have a clue what to do
and asha renegotiated the deal and took
it over and they owned the oil so then
iran became super powerful education got
better
things got better frank sinatra is to
party over there everybody used to go
over there elizabeth taylor used to date
zahid all these things happened to iran
and iran became a place
where rich people would go to and some
people weren't happy about it and let's
face it
the shop iran got a little bit uh too
confident in a couple interviews again
with bbc
said that the blue-eyed people are
taking too many
sleeping medicines i don't know if you
remember that interview or not when that
took place
and uh he said within five years we'll
be the size that you are and within 25
years we'll be competing with other
western companies
and he had a smirk on his face when he
said that it's almost a
method of competition we're coming after
and i don't know if politicians like
that
because the more turmoil in the middle
east the more control the less turmoil
the more control you know it's
it's it's a it's a it's an interesting
dynamic of what happened i just thought
maybe you had inside that maybe we
didn't have
yeah and it's also interesting that this
guy was very close to the shah but my
friend's father who had been
who was a general um and close to the
shah
you know said that he thought that shah
was losing it mentally that he was
you know he was he was losing at the
dementia or something of course we know
he had cancer
so yeah it's it's very very
complex but it's always been it's always
been
mind-boggling to me to try to understand
exactly what happened and
how you know if the cia wasn't
involved in the overthrow of iran then
how could the cia have been so
blindsided it's one thing for me to be
blindsided i don't speak
farsi but people in the cia certainly
did they certainly had operatives they
certainly had access
to savak the the the shah's
very brutal secret service the cia was
deeply involved with savaka had been
uh so he's actually trained to survive
actually
yeah exactly the savak was
which is a interesting would train them
you know
well yeah and that's true you know so
throughout the americas too in latin
america where you had the school of
americas but yeah so it's it's hard to
believe that the cia was really
blindsided the way
we business people were but um
i i just don't know i wish i knew more
did you ever have a face to face with
the shah or no just to did you ever have
a chance to meet him
yes i met him it was always with other
people it was not a one-to-one
sort of meeting like i had with roldos
and and torrijos in latin america
uh it was it was it was group things but
yeah i certainly met him and shook his
hand and
you know did you ever deal with zahidi
or no
his ambassador u.s ambassador zohaibi
or zahadi no you never dealt with them
no you know
for me for a guy that was born there i
had my family who
one side they were too they i don't know
if you remember what two day community
is
remember the two day okay they were the
communists which uh
a lot of times was linked to because
mossad was more like a
modern-day bernie sanders you know he
was more of a socialist and he kind of
wanted to
he didn't like the fact that shaw's
family got rich because of oil and all
this other stuff and
so there was a community that didn't
like uh the
shah and a lot of the people in iran
getting rich and then you had the other
side that was
loving how iran was growing and
expanding and reinvesting and so
just like any i mean you're seeing some
of that in america right now you look at
america right now
there are a lot of people that are not
happy with america creating a lot of
wealth every time you hear somebody
become a millionaire it's almost like
you have to keep it a secret
are you a millionaire no no no no i'm
not no michael moore
don't ever sound worth 50 million
dollars i'm broke i'm just a regular guy
i know i made a video about this
you're seeing all of these people in
america today that are embarrassed to
say that they're living the american
dream where at one point it used to be
like
the ultimate goal you come to america to
live the american dream and there was
some of that going on with iran
i asked because you know i got family
i'm raising my kids here i want to make
sure that doesn't happen in the country
i've chosen to live in
uh to see what's going on here so you
know just out of curiosity for someone
like you
what do you think is the biggest threat
america has today
we have a lot of different things that
we're hearing about you're hearing about
bio warfare
cyber attack you know you're hearing
about
proxy wars china tariffs
brexit venezuela oil maduro the border
you know all of these things that's
going on for someone like you that
some tells me you're not you're not
saying everything that you know because
you kind of want to also you don't want
to say the wrong thing to piss off the
wrong person i kind of get a feeling you
kind of hold them back a little bit
which is fine
i can respect that but let's see if we
can get an answer from you from someone
that has experience for the rest of us
to uh uh kind of position ourselves
better what do you think is the biggest
threat today to america
i think it's i think i think it's us i i
think that
the divisions that have been occurring
in this country the fact that
our our poli our congress seems to be
you know still
stalemated right now we've we've got
this you know the the democrats and
republicans fighting over
what are we going to do with the 600 a
week which what's next what are we and
so
so nothing happens and you know
i i i'm terribly concerned with the way
that we budget things so for example
you know 54. of every hundred dollars
you pay
in taxes all right and the american who
pays u.s taxes 54
out of every 100 in the discretionary
budget goes to the military
and the the military is spending a hell
of a lot of money
on aircraft carriers and other things
that are kind of outdated in this time
of
drones and cybernetics the chinese the
russians they're spending their money
they spend a lot less you know we spend
our military budget is as large as the
next 10 countries combined
and we're spending it on things that
give basically pork barrel to every
state every state has
benefits from the big military budget so
every every congress person
wants to keep the budget growing and
keep it
making stuff that's to a large degree
outdated
i wish we would spend a lot more money
on cybernetics
i think our threat is from china and
russia
is not from aircraft carriers it's it's
from
cybernetics it's from attack on our
voting system it's from the
the tremendous campaigns that we know
they've been launching over social media
to biased people in this country and to
undermine our election process
i i wish we'd spent a lot more money on
that sort of stuff but instead
we quibble over these ancient methods
and and i think also um that
somehow how do we come together to get
out of this divisiveness because this
divisiveness
is hurting us it's it's you know i
actually fear
that we could result in some sort of
really strong clash i
don't want to use the word civil war
because that conjures up you know the
trench warfare of the
of the civil war of the 1800s but i
think we're going through
a very deep divide right now
which is dangerous to us and the world
sees this
countries like russia and china who
there's no doubt in my mind
they want to take over they're in the
process of china's in the process of
taking over
and they see these incredible weaknesses
and they know how to go in
and exploit these weaknesses and they do
it
to a very large degree through
technology uh you know
the computer technology ai technology
cybernetics
um so i think our threat the biggest
threat to us is that we're not keeping
up to date
we're not staying in tune with where the
world really is today
we need to be really really careful
around china
especially china also russia but
especially china and i don't think we're
playing it very smart in the way that
we're dealing with china i think we're
dealing with china like it was some
you know like like like we're dealing in
the time of world war ii well this isn't
the time of world war ii this isn't even
the time of the vietnam war the korean
war this is a time
where we've reached an exponential
increase
in the power of technology and the power
of ai and the power
of social networking and i don't think
we're keeping up with it and that
bothers me it concerns me a great deal
so so what what do you mean by we're not
dealing with china properly how would
you deal with china how would you have
handled it
well for one thing i would strengthen
our own abilities to protect ourselves
from cyber attacks uh from virus attacks
put put more emphasis on our on our
health care systems
on on our social networking systems on
our educational systems
you know to really bring our people up
to date as to what's going on in the
world i don't think we're doing a good
job of
really keeping people informed of what
the real threats
are here when do you think is the last
time we did a good job at those things
hmm i think we started making
the mistakes when the soviet union
collapsed
in 91 dayton i think at that time
we became rather arrogant we were the
world's only superpower suddenly
so up until that time we've been
competing with the united states we kept
pretty sharp
uh i mean we've been competing with the
soviet union we
we kept pretty sharp once the soviet
union collapsed
we kind of just i think focused on on
materialistic gain and spreading
corporations
exploiting other countries rather than
really
keeping up on things and then you know
china took a huge advantage
of the period when we went into
afghanistan we went into iraq
and then afghanistan so after 9 11 i
think
one of the biggest benefits for 9 11 was
china
and i'm not suggesting china did 9 11
i'm just suggesting that they knew how
to take advantage of the united states
suddenly up until that time we've been
watching china we've been careful about
our trade deals with china
but after 9 11 we were so focused
on iraq and afghanistan and the middle
east
that we we kind of lost track of china
and during that time
china just rose up i mean it it it
truly rose up and be and is now the you
know
another superpower there's no question
about that we're not alone anymore we're
not the sole superpower so i think we
we blew it during that period when we
had a tremendous opportunity
to to really influence the entire world
with our and and bring our systems to
bear on the on the world and in a good
way
so when's the last time we did it right
all those things you talked about
because that's when we did it wrong so
essentially you're saying reagan
but when did we do it right well that's
a tough question to answer because
i'm not sure you can never say anybody
ever did it completely right
but we came out of world war ii as
the world's hero and is a an example to
be followed
a leader the leadership area to be
followed
and it you know there was a there was a
whole process
during the next years where i think
where where i think that we
we moved in that direction i think the
vietnam war
was a big mistake because that also
pissed off a lot of the world and in the
end showed the world that
that we couldn't that our form of
warfare failed against uh
a different kind of warfare um
and you know what's interesting patrick
i think it was it was after
vietnam during this period so when i was
an economic hitman that that the whole
decision was made warfare like that
doesn't work
so let's expand our our way of
dealing with the world through economic
hitman
so we we lose in vietnam
mid mid 70s and after that the whole
emphasis
was on doing things the way that i'd
done things through economics
through that kind of a process of loans
of building up countries of
going in with the infrastructure but it
reached a point
i think in the late 1990s during the
time of clinton
when the people many corporations had
gained
from this economic hitman era but the
military
industrial complex as eisenhower defined
it
hadn't gained it was losing it wasn't it
wasn't wasn't it wasn't doing what it
wanted to do
and was putting tremendous pressure i
think they put a lot of pressure on
clinton
i think that 9 11 came along and it gave
the perfect excuse
to go back in and gear up to the
military process
so since 9 11 we've had the t we've had
both things going on there's been the
military approach and also the economic
hitmen approach has continued
but but during that process as i
mentioned earlier
because we put such a huge emphasis on
the wars in the middle east
we lost sight of china we forgot
that china was the rising dragon that's
you know and now we're suddenly you know
we woke up we wake up and we look around
and say oh my god
what's happened they're taking over what
are we going to do about it you know
trade embargoes and so on and so forth
what are we going to do about it
so so what do you say to the folks where
like you know what you're saying right
now
i had a lot of people here that read
your book because it's uh
it's fascinating what you're writing
about and it kind of i believe there's a
lot of it going on today and you got a
lot of people speculating saying
this economic hitman job china's
mastering
and what do you say to those that they
had
a president like trump who's the most
difficult person the
person china has dealt with keeps
putting tariffs on top of tariffs on top
of tariffs on top of tariffs
and china did the ultimate economic hit
job which is the world economic hit job
by releasing a virus that got into all
these other countries and
trillions of dollars was lost around the
world based on
a virus like that do you think there is
any chance
any chance that a part of that virus had
to do with an economic hitman's
job philosophy that you have to say you
don't want to negotiate with us you're
strong-arming me
watch what i'm going to do to you do you
think any chance of that could take
place
with what happened recently with
coronavirus my personal opinion no
why is that because
china suffered from it too i think the
united states
made huge mistakes if china wanted to to
show us as a country that's really
failed and taking care of its people it
certainly succeeded in that
you know a country with less than five
percent of the world's population has
about 25
of the coronavirus deaths that's that's
unacceptable that's ridiculous the
largest economy in the history of the
world and we can't take care of our
people
so the virus certainly showed our
weaknesses up so if china had wanted to
do that they've certainly succeeded
but it's really difficult for me to
believe that
that anybody would create a virus like
that and have it hit their own country
and spread around the world
anything's possible i know that from
from from my own experiences
there's always stories behind the story
so there's always that possibility i
would never say
never but in my opinion i think that's
extremely unlikely i think it you know
and people like
like bill gates had had had prophesies
that
projected that there would be a virus
about five or six years ago he said this
is likely to happen
many medical authorities have said that
it was bound to happen at some point
we were poorly prepared for it and i in
my opinion we've
uh our national government has has
made a terrible job of dealing with the
situation
got it you know i mean if if you're
saying the fact that you know
uh a country with five percent of the
world population has 25 percent of death
that means china doesn't have that many
deaths which means it kind of worked out
for them
right if if it was because it didn't
really hurt them as much as
you're saying it hurt america it
destroyed america if it's like a
quarter of all the death that took place
based on the data that you're saying
so that means it could be possible that
they did do it and it was victorious for
them no
yeah thailand's done really well too
they've had even fewer deaths because
they've got such a good health care
system
so it's possible that thailand created
the the virus and planted it in a
chinese factory
the fact of the matter is you could say
that about almost every country because
the one that's done most poorly is the
united states so i think no i'm only
saying it to you because you are the guy
that
wrote the book economic hit shock which
is which which gets
us who live in america to sit there and
say if america did it to so many people
maybe china's now retaliating and doing
it the ultimate way i don't know i'm not
the one that's speculating i'm just wait
wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute we we never
created a virus we never did anything i
never said virus i never said
like that i mean it's fair warfare i
never said bio warfare
i just said the model of an economic
because everybody when you read the
you know business model of china the
u.s you make a very good point when you
say 54 we're investing into buying ships
and buying this and buying that what for
how much of that war is really taking
place today why don't we spend some of
that money into
protecting ourselves in a different
military way cyber security all of a
sudden it's a very very accurate
statement you're making
absolutely the right people i'm hoping
listen to this and realize maybe we need
to
go in the direction what you're talking
about you know the next war is not going
to be the war that we're accustomed to
seeing from the 70s and 80s and
world war ii or world war one we're
seeing the bio warfare
can destroy economies and shut down an
entire nation
and the one country that's always
bragged about being the best and that
isn't america it's always been china
so that's why a part of this speculation
when you come in
and in the middle of the interview my
brain just went wait a minute if that's
what if there you know it could be
possibility i don't know people have
brought it up to me let me just ask john
since he's the expert here so and and
the other part is you know
the the complete opposite argument of
the five percent of world's population
u.s 300 million of 7.5 billion yet
25 of the death that's also assuming
john that the data china has given the
world is accurate no
true true it does assume that
you're right it's tough to trust a
nation that doesn't have free press
it is you're right no that's i don't
trust china i'm not saying that i that i
trust china but i am
i think what if you look historically
countries that wage
war in other countries usually want to
have pretty good control over the
weapons it's one of the reasons that
countries fear nuclear weapons because
we fear that we don't really have that
much control once you set off the
nuclear reaction
who knows where that's going to go so
that you know based on history
it it's hard for me to believe that you
release a virus
around the world and you don't have much
control over you don't know who it's
going to hit and
so to me you know i'm not saying that
biological warfare
can't happen or isn't happening possibly
it is but
if it is we're in we're in
really really deep trouble uh and
does it does that mean we should
retaliate with our own biological
weapons no not at all zero what does it
mean
no not at all i don't think that well
let's say that we we actually
we actually proved that china did do
this what would be our response
i'd be curious to know what you say to
because i have my own ideas what would
you do to it
if if it's proven that this did happen
and you know the
we take him to the tribunal and we put
him on court everybody does the
investigation everything happens yep
they started it they released it they
knew what's happening
and it caused shambles around the [ __ ]
around the world
what do you think needs to happen to
china
that anybody could do i can't possibly
imagine
i really can't patrick what do you think
i got to tell you i'm learning how you
sat down with these prime ministers and
presidents and
i hope all the audience was taking notes
i mean have you noticed how phenomenal
he is
first of all your january 28th baby
which which i'm i'm putting all the
pieces together uh you're january 28th
i'm thinking you're january 28th no
that's true what does that mean i just
i'm a math guy and you know
i got a weird side of me of putting this
is a
puzzle together forget about that part
but for me i put numbers together
but uh yeah i have my own ideas what i
would do but uh
you know like i said john i'm an
entrepreneur what do i know i'm just a
regular guy
you know i'm a guy that's an insurance
guy i'm a business guy i'm sitting down
with the man that sat down with prime
ministers and presidents i'm asking you
with your intellect
you went to school with a killer gpa you
killed it with all your grades and
you were somebody that wanted to prove a
point that you can beat these rich kids
in grade you embarrass them with your
grades you're the smart one here i'm
just a regular guy here
so you've been you've made a hell of a
lot more money than i have you've been a
lot more successful in business than i
have
and incidentally i'm not an economist
anymore i haven't been an economist for
years
i write i read books on jaguars i write
books
you know this is about transforming fear
into actions to change your life in the
world
it's no longer i confessed about being
an economic hitman but i haven't been
one for a long long long time
i don't pretend to know much about that
world now i'm writing about how we
transform these things and i think
you know what we really need to look at
now patrick is that that
we have created an economic system
that's causing a lot of problems it's
causing climate change the the
the glaciers are melting the polar bears
are out there standing on single ice
icebergs the oceans are rising species
are going extinct
uh there's you know there's this the the
the income inequality
is huge and you know what we've really
done is we've created an economic system
that's that's consuming itself into
extinction what i call
a death economy and we better look at
that and it's very very likely
that that most of our problems are like
even the coronavirus
all the the racial issues
are they're all problems but they're not
the problem they are symptoms of the
problem and the the problem is that is a
system that we
have created globally a governmental
social economic system
that puts way too much emphasis on
short-term maximization of consumption
materialistic consumption
and in the process our industries are
consuming the very resources that they
depend on
for the long run they're consuming those
things in the short run
they're doing whatever it takes to
maximize short-term profits i'm sure
you're doing the same thing i'm sure
you're
you're guilty you know you're you're in
that business short-term profits
but you know what historically that's
never worked
historically the successful societies
and and we've all been part of those for
the last 250 000 years or so
most all those years people have looked
at well how do we take care of our kids
and our grandchildren how do we take
care of the long run
resources whereas today it's this short
term if you study
if you study the the business model and
by the way i'm going to still come back
to china question for you so that was
good for you to digress but i'm going to
come back and ask you from you one more
time so brace yourself
emotionally get ready do what you're
going to say because i'm coming back i'm
not teasing you i'm preparing you
because brilliant i want to hear you
i've got my jaguar protecting protecting
me here
i'm ready i'm ready for this chinese
going back to going back to what you're
saying you know i have i have to
you know we have to realize that you
know john you're brilliant you're not
you know you're not saying what you're
saying because you're
you you've been around and you've
studied a lot of different data but you
know if you know business models you
know amazon the biggest criticism
bazel's got for the longest time is
because his shareholders used to
complain that he didn't pay out
dividends
and they used to say how come we're not
getting any dividends why are your
profit margins so low why are your pro
and bazel is like dude i'm not solving
for profit today
if you're patient with me we're going to
do big things
so when he first started a company he
went to 20 uh
40 different people and you raised 50
000 a piece which is 2 million dollars
those people that gave 2 million he gave
them 20
of the company that 2 million dollars
that was 20
of the companies worth 200 billion
dollars today okay so
he came in he says i'm not going after
profit i'm going from value like for
myself
i'm not the highest paid guy in the
company i've not been the highest paid
guy in the company
at all because i wasn't taking profits i
was
rebuilding value value value
infrastructure putting back putting back
putting back putting back
and then it led to what it led to and
god knows how much money we've given
back to charities and different kind of
foundations and things we've done so
pure business model doesn't work if you
chase profit
long term it only works if you chase
value and then you have an
infrastructure and then you
of course you have a lot of power at
that time you and i both know like today
when people talk about who's got the
power in america
is it politicians or large corporations
who would you say
it's an easy answer politicians or
corporations who's got the power in
america
corporations there you go i i don't
think anybody disputes that that's why
there's crony capitalism
it's very ugly what's going on with all
these guys buying people behind closed
doors
but i'm going to go back to the question
if
wait wait let me let me let me respond
to what you said for just tournament
okay
yeah so i think i would dispute with you
the the
description of that model because i
think bezos and i suspect you
did make huge profits made huge profits
in certain sectors of the business
and plowed those rather than taking
those profits of claiming them as profit
they were profits
but he plowed them back into buying
other businesses and i don't know
whether you did that or not but i know
bezos did that he bought more and more
businesses
he was making profits but he was also
plowing those profits into other
businesses
he didn't take it out like to say all he
cares about is taking a profit side the
guy was trying to build an empire and
compete against the bigger guys
yeah that's right yeah yes smoking
mirrors
no profits yeah
we're going to sink them into the long
term to increase value i'm
that's smart i'm not saying it's not
smart it's smart but it
would be it's a little misleading to say
that his businesses didn't make profits
no it wasn't it wasn't known as the
biggest ebitda profit margins in place
there's more bigger margins than other
businesses that they could take
that's true that's true of amazon.com
but a lot of the other businesses that
that have spun off from that you're
right i don't i don't i don't dispute
listen i'm not sitting here
for one of my questions i had on the
list was how do we fix crony capitalism
that was one of my questions i had for
you i was curious to know what you would
say
because i don't think the left nor the
right has figured out a way to
to solve crony capitalism and i i think
it's happening on both sides so
since you're the chief economist and
former economic hit man how would you
fix crony capitalism today
or is it are we in too deep that we
can't fix it
no i never think we're in too deep i you
can't believe that
uh i i think crony capitalism is a
reflection
of that guy sitting over your your left
shoulder there with the glasses on and
the red necktie
it's interesting he's wearing a red
necktie what do you think that
symbolizes
just kidding it's the same reason why
this guy's wearing a blue necktie yeah
i think what symbolizes the fact that
this guy's just saying i'm not wearing
any color
the leader that's this is the guy i'm
curious about
yeah so milton friedman over there over
your left shoulder
you know this has been growing for a
long time but when he won the nobel
prize in 1976
you know the probably the most important
statement he made and i'm paraphrasing
here is the only responsibility of
business is to maximize
short-term profits regardless of the
social and environmental costs
and that really created crony capitalism
if you want to go there because what it
does is it tells every ceo
that they have it tells every ceo that
you've not only got the right but you
get the mandate to do whatever
it takes to maximize short-term profits
including including buying politicians
which now is done legally
because they passed the laws to make it
legal but it's still what you're calling
crony capitalism
including forming monopolies monopsonies
and and including destroying the very
resources upon which your business
depends in the long term
the idea of maximizing short term
anything is contrary to most life as we
know it on this planet
i think you're i think in slang terms
they would say john perkins you're
reaching right now
yes you're you're out of pocket is what
they would say okay
but the proper the who
but maybe the term that may be making
sense it's a little bit of spinning
going on there the guy said the number
one job
meaning like the interpretation was your
job is to make profit you're not you are
not
forced to it's like saying hey you
better give ten percent to church no no
i'm gonna choose to give ten percent
future you can't force me to give ten
percent to church
i'm gonna give to charity you can't
force me to get you can force me to pay
taxes
which is what a lot of politicians do
but you can't force me to
get my profits i got to make sure i stay
in business so i understand that part
i don't think he was saying go buy
politicians that's not what he was
saying
but that's maybe that's not what he was
saying but that's how it wasn't
we have so this is this is almost like
biblical studies
and and we're reading one scripture from
galatians 1 6
and your interpretation is one thing and
my interpretation is another thing and
the viewers have to decide for
themselves
some are guys know that you grew up in
iran you're probably a zoroastrian right
i am a uh so i grew up atheists for 25
years my parents were both
uh christian and 25 years later after
going and studying jehovah witness
seventh day judaism christianity
scientology all this stuff
the closest thing i felt that worked for
me was non-denominational christian
that's where i'm at that's where i'm at
strange dynamic here by the way i was a
die-hard atheist
die-hard atheist when you live in iran
and you see people dying and getting
bombed on it's very hard to believe in a
god
especially a loving god very hard so
again you're talking to a very weird
person here john it's
not as weird i've not reached your level
i'm not
gonna say patrick that's the one thing
we'd probably agree on
let me get back to my question i'll ask
the last question
if china really if
if china really did do what we talked
about earlier
honestly what should be the punishment
if if that really did take place
i suppose that you know
ideally speaking the world gangs up on
china
and does everything possible to impose
sanctions
to impose everything um on china uh
that would have to be a a unified effort
of a
whole lot of most of the world and i i'm
not sure that would happen
i don't know i don't know how i don't
know how that goes because i think so
much of the world economy today depends
on china
including the us economy i mean without
china
what happens to our economy 80
pharmaceuticals
relying on 80 percent yeah high tech
high tech i mean you talk we talked
about amazon we saw you talk about
uh you know apple what happens to them
without china
so i i i think
ideally i think whatever the idealistic
response to this is
frankly speaking i suspect that if
the nsa or the or mi6 or
anybody discovers that china caused this
virus
they would do everything they could to
keep it secret because
the the the implications
to answer the question if it became
public that china did this
what's the correct response
is probably a response that would be
almost
suicidal economically for everybody so
that's a very very difficult question
you've asked and i have a feeling that
we will never prove that china did this
if they did and as i said earlier i
doubt they did but i
i don't know i don't know whether they
did or not but if they did
what is the correct response and and so
i throw it back to you you said you had
a response what would your response be
i don't know if i would ever uh accept
anybody traveling from china to here
nor to any other country that accepts
travel from china
or any other country that accepts travel
from a country that accepts travel from
china i don't know if you understood
what i just said those three different
steps that i just
covered right there and number two what
i would do is
if we're gonna negotiate and you want me
to get rid of the tariffs you need to
allow every single country to have
press in your country and allow every
major social media company of us to have
freedom
of being used by your citizens which
means uh
us bbc is in china nbc cnn fox
is in china msnbc and china you know abc
every one of these guys are in china and
uh
facebook youtube twitter it's in china
that's what i would be doing
or else i'm just not negotiating the
deal with you because i have
nowadays they're calling them citizen
journalists right these are people that
are walking on with a phone and it's
facebook live and you can't see what's
going on
citizen journalists are almost more
powerful today than the people working
at cnn fox and uh
msnbc because you're seeing it right
there with a 22 year old kid holding a
cell phone
if we got 1.5 billion chinese citizens
that have access to a cell phone that's
on facebook youtube twitter
and i can see exactly what's going on
then maybe we can renegotiate
outside of that they're going to be
paying some fines and i would probably
cut the u.s debt that they have and i
would say that forgiveness needs to come
through
because we're not paying you the 1.06
trillion dollars of debt that we owe you
you cost us more
more than that that's what i would do
but again i'm just an entrepreneur
so so so patrick if you did that do you
think you'd still have a cell phone
yes i would where would it come from
u.s i just would have to pay 50 more to
it
you got to realize well wait a minute
china owns most of the mineral mines the
the minerals that are necessary to go
into that cell phone or owned by china
okay
so the difference between two of us is i
believe in capitalism tremendously i
just don't believe in crony capitalism
and and the model of capitalism that i
believe in the model of capitalism that
i believe in is the following deal
china taking a hit right now there are a
lot of other people
that are very excited i don't undermine
the level of brilliance and ingenuity
that's being built in
india with 1.4 billion people where they
have the number one engineering school
in the world that's even better than mit
called iit
which i've spoken to in front of 5 000
of their engineers graduating class of
i don't know what it was 2016 or 2017
2018 when we were there
i trust that competition is going to go
high with a prime minister
uh of the leader of india that's going
to compete the leader of other nations
around the world that are going to
compete
you're getting armenia that's developing
incredible engineers they're calling it
the silicon valley of
russia with the armenian engineers that
are coming up incredible engineers
coming out of colombia nowadays i know
it sounds weird saying colombia but
a lot of other places so i think
competition
officially became open and i think a lot
of countries are sitting there saying
great we'll do it for you for cheap
we'll do it for you for cheap we'll do
it for you for cheap
i think it benefits the world economy i
think it hurts the china economy
well i like that perspective that's a
that's a really good perspective
and uh um assuming that all these that's
why i say i think we need to
bring in most of the rest of the
countries in the world would have to
agree with us to go along with this and
that that would be the
that would be the interesting aspect and
incidentally
as a former atheist i i just wonder
on your right hand side there this seems
to be it's a god or something sitting
next to you that you keep referring
things to
over here there's some but this there's
an entity over there
yeah you get your right hand pen up you
turn to this entity periodically
and ask for advice and what year this
was and i just i
i would love to see that entity what is
that over there are you asking what
these two statues are
no i'm asking about the person that you
actually asked voice questions like what
year were we in
what year were we in china what we don't
know what year was i was i speaking
at the indian university at itt oh i'm
sorry it's mario mario's sitting over
here he's mario's the guy you were
talking to from guatemala when you guys
were speaking in uh
you guys spoke in spanish no yes mario
is uh
here let me do this so you can see
mario's who you spoke to up here he's
sitting over here
i was just trying to give you a hard
time patrick about this
you've got to consult this you've got
you've got these advisors next to you
all i have over here is a 10 week old
kitten
well the one thing you need to know
about mario is mario went to uh
harvard he got his uh bachelors from
harvard he got his
masters in economy from wharton business
school went to oxford for two years
but all of that is bs because he doesn't
even have a two-year degree
that's mario i've known mario since he
was 18 years old working at dry cleaners
in la
and how old was i when the first time
you met me i was what 26.
14 years ago i was 26 27 years old
you're talking to a couple people
without college degrees we're regular
people here john
average and ordinary american citizens
that's what we are here
so let me tell you patrick it's funny
that i was chief economist at this major
consulting firm
my only degree is a bachelor of science
in business administration
i don't have an mba i'm not you know and
i always used to say
i'm a terrible economist i really am but
i knew enough to hire
people that could create because i
wouldn't have i wouldn't know how to
create an econometric model but i hired
people who knew how to create
econometric models and you know one time
i gave you the guy who was
the guy my second in command in my
department
i hired this phd from uh harvard
business school
and this guy was the second man cameron
comes up to me and says hey aren't you
afraid this guy's gonna take you over
your job he's got a lot better
credentials than you
you do and i say yeah well that's why
i'm hiring he's got the credentials
but he's not a good con artist like me
wow what is an economic hitman a con
artist exactly
who then uses perception we get back to
this perception
jesus who uses the phds to create these
fancy reports and econometric models to
convince people
to do things that he wants to convince
them to do and i'm just glad that you
weren't president of one of those
countries that i was up against because
i don't think you would i don't think he
would have bought into my deals
necessarily and i and you're such a nice
sweet guy
i would not want to have to call in the
jackals on you
listen i will take that as an unofficial
threat is what i'll take out
that's an unofficial threat if i were
president but thank god i'm just a
business guy
john i'm gonna do a quick speed round
i'll give you a name tell me one word
that comes to mind if you don't have any
just say no comment
uh milton friedman short-term profits
edward snort
snowden um
spy okay julian assange
idiot jeff bezos oh
um oligarchy uh
george bush w which one was that first
to the second
the sun the sun hmm
incompetent okay saddam hussein
villain omar torrijos
charismatic uh jaime rodes aguilera
integrity saudi crown prince
control trump
divisive
democrat okay karl marx
marxist uh muhammad
that was supposed to bring a laugh it
did of course i'm like
the safest answer he could give was
jesus it
took you a while i'm trying to hold my
face while you're saying it for the
audience to not see it
but you have another one for him or are
you sticking to marxist
uh he's a good he was a good marxist
okay it was a good mark i think it's a
fair assessment
mohammed was
dictator okay churchill
churchill it's a good one
shrewd rude out of all the words
and last but not least your favorite fdr
well i gotta do two two words there new
deal new deal
fair enough well john i got to tell you
i've had a blast with you
i i've really enjoyed this conversation
i know we went to a million different
places
and thank you for accommodating the
conversation and being nimble and
going through it and taking some of the
questions i know we once we went a
million different directions but this
was a blast
by the way if you're watching this folks
i'm telling i highly
highly i don't just say this to all the
books i highly
recommend you get his books i highly
we're going gonna put all the links
below
we're gonna put the links to the the
both economic hitman and we're gonna put
the links below to the book that you
just saw as well
um anybody that's in the world of
business anybody that's in the world of
business you have to know that you will
sit down with people like him
with the competitor in some sense and
you're going to have to figure out ways
to survive in a competitive world
and he explains it so eloquently highly
recommend going to listen to
if you're not going to buy it at least
buy his audio book and listen to it
john i'll give you the final words
before we wrap up here any final words
you got for the listeners
patrick i'm i'm so grateful that you do
what you do
because i think that this is the essence
of democracy
it's the essence of true pure capitalism
which i
am totally in favor of a dialogue like
this of getting things out into the open
it's so important at this time in our
our our history and then these difficult
times we're going through that we get
these things out there and that we have
discussions like this
it's very important that we disagree
that we have the ability to disagree
that we listen to each other and we can
disagree and learn from it i've learned
a lot from you today
i appreciate that and to your listeners
i'd say you know i think we should all
understand that we live in blessed times
and this isn't to detract from the
terrible suffering the deaths
all the difficult things people are
going through but we really live at a
time when we have the opportunity
to communicate like this we have the
opportunity to see
what's going on in the world where we're
living at a very very auspicious time in
human history
excuse me and i think we should be
grateful uh that we're
alive at this time and i'm grateful and
and i deeply appreciate
what you're doing patrick and and mario
is
from guatemala i take groups of people
at guatemala
in january i'm planning on going down
and hanging out with the mayan shamans i
think the two of you ought to join me
we keep the group small 15 people
intimate
uh we could you know you and i could
entertain the
the other people for most of the time
they're having this discussion
but seriously i think i think you'd love
to do that it's it's a great we
spent a lot of time with mayan shamans
who are very very
brilliant people and and open the doors
to other ways of thinking so
please uh you and mario join us and all
you listen and
well another 13 of your listeners also
i can definitely tell you i will
definitely entertain i went back to
guatemala to tikal portobarrios
livingston
back in 06 december 26 through december
31st i i had a
in tikal grande agua i had an incredible
time in guatemala i went 14 years ago so
we would say you will see tikal in a new
way if you go
with us and we spend several days there
including ceremonies at night with the
shamans it's the information about it
and it's so you can just go to
johnperkins.org and it's
all the information is there but we'll
definitely do that
but you know you you you know you and i
are going to be debating the entire time
to us what i don't we'll be entertaining
everybody the entire time
by the way john i too have learned a lot
from speaking to you today
uh your perspective is very very helpful
and i definitely appreciate that
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment thank you
well you're welcome and this has been
one of the most challenging and fun
interviews i've done and to say it's
challenging is a real compliment and and
i enjoy that i enjoy that thank you so
much
thank you great work patrick thank you
what was your biggest takeaway from this
interview i mean you saw when we talked
about china
iran the shah many different angles some
politics they didn't want to go to it we
kind of went there had to go three times
to talk about china he finally opened up
give a little bit of insight
was it a job that they did was it
intentional was it accidental how should
they be held accountable
i want to hear from you comment below i
got two other interviews i want you to
watch
if you enjoyed this interview one of
them is with uh general spalding that
was done seven months ago
pre-chronovirus which he explains
when he went and lived in china what is
china's game plan by
made in china 2025 with the china silent
takeover
how china took over while the americas
elite slept if you've not watched us
watch it the other one is an interview i
did with
joshua phillip from uh epoch times which
is
very very deep on what he reveals about
china click over here to watch this one
if you've not watched it before
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye